attribuer de mexico de mexicains sait
trop sur une estrade
[Musique]
merci j'ai moi qui allait mettre fin à
ma carrière de scénariste
[Rires]
à ce prix il me ramène à ma solitude
initial et elle est totalement
contredite par la suite de l' aventure
puisque ça a été qu une ronde de regard
que cette cette ronde de regards
collaboratif c'était la plus belle
aventure de ma vie de cinéaste
permettez moi de me détacher de cette
récompense et puis de parler des gens
qui ont donné la vie de parler du regard
de kermat ton chef opératrice tu
regardes delphine d'eau l'assistante
mise en ciel du regard de christelle
barras directrice de casting du regard
de julien lâcherait monteur du regard
sous lequel j'ai grandi de bénédicte
ouvreur ma productrice et puis tu
regardes adèle haenel et noémie ni
merlans
à qui bien sûr je dois merci éternelle
et à 12 ans d'écart elles ont passé la
porte et j'ai vu le futur
voilà merci a commencé hier de la
première palme portrait de la jeune
fille un fou raconte la naissance d'une
passion amoureuse sur une île bretonne
l'après midi qu'un siècle vendu nos
peintres sa model jeune femme souhaitait
se marier quelques mois plus tard il
marquait l'entrée en compétition de
l'année smith yamaha qui avait présenté
naissance des pieuvres acquis un certain
regard et bandes de filles à la
quinzaine des réalisateurs
il sortira en salles le 18 septembre
[Musique]